[Musique]
musée classique et vidéos clips font bon
ménage pour la violoniste angèle dubeau
dont le clip flying a récolté plusieurs
prix à l'international
oui ça ouvre des portes oui ça fait
jaser oui ça vient titiller l'oreille de
gens qui disent j'ai adoré la musique de
ce que je viens de voir
[Musique]
ce virage vers l'image en musique
classique fait de plus en plus d'adeptes
la flûtiste nadia l'abri est en plein
tournage au cirque éloize de son premier
vidéoclip en carrière et l'interprète du
mozart sous la pluie on doit faire
maintenant on peut pas passer on peut
plus passer à côté d'autres sont
maintenant en l'air des réseaux sociaux
a l'air de 2
de l'image finalement je pensais je
pense que c'était le bon moment de
d'explorer finalement cette avenue là
des vidéos ont misé classique
[Musique]
le violoniste alexandre da costa pousse
la note encore plus loin avec était de
vivaldi il décoiffe son public et brasse
la cage de l'industrie et puis c'est
vidéoclip là c'est le tour du monde moi
j'aimerais ça que ma musique soit perçu
que quelque chose qui est aussi cool que
certains courants artistiques qui
aujourd'hui sont considérés comme la
référence par les jeunes
le vidéoclip est d'abord et avant tout
une carte de visite mais le milieu de la
musique classique et parfois
conservateur et très peu de ces
musiciens aux utiliser les clips pour
l'instant l'industrie de la musique
classique entente elle est très
conservatrice très content traditionnels
et les halles est gérée par des gens qui
font du copier coller depuis des
décennies
les temps changent et avec sa musique
sur les réseaux de diffusion en continu
et ses vidéos
angèle dubeau rejouer un large public
iliad se réjouit de voir sa musique
rayonner aux quatre coins de la planète
c'est hallucinant moi même je n'en crois
pas mes oreilles mais je viens de te
dépasser les 120 millions de stream
ici lui fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal
[Musique]